you do have one of the prettiest shots
in the league though so tell me three
other guys that you think have very
pretty shots I think Klay Thompson shot
is like picture perfect like balance you
know elbow straight obviously how Step
Shoes we work out quite a bit together
and I just think his range I admire
shooting because there's two different
ways guys shoot you know some guys shoot
a push shot and they can extend their
range back and then there's like jump
Shooters who shoot kind of like me with
the with the higher release Point like
Damian Lillard we saw it up close when
he was getting a 50 in the playoffs a
couple years ago book has an amazing
shot he was killing us this year for a
couple games but yeah that's a few guys
who I think are great shooters